let me ask you about the end here what
are the various trajectories this war
can take in your view uh what are some
of the end States as you've said which
are
desirable and are
achievable I I mentioned this earlier
but whenever I would get a problem set
in government I'd always think through
from a first principal perspective
what's the logical outcome right and
forget about all the reasons why can't
happen that's what everyone in
governments always rush to talk about
but I do think here number one Israel
has to have a secure environment where
they don't feel threatened from uh from
from Gaza and number two is the people
in Gaza need to have an environment
where they feel uh like they can live a
better life and have opportunities so
that's the end State and so I think that
the International Community should come
together I do think that uh the people
who are usually putting blame on Israel
should now realize that maybe they've
been a little bit harsh here and that
Hamas has been as big a threat if not an
even bigger threat than Israel has been
saying and I do think that if the
International Community comes together
and unites behind Israel and really
forces Hamas and their Iranian backers
to stop hostilities to stop saber
rattling to stop um misrepresenting uh
the history uh in order to justify their
violent behavior and if they say instead
we want hold you accountable no more
money and they all say that they're
going to stand behind Israel's efforts
to eliminate uh their National Security
threats um and then we will all come
together and only fund again into a
framework that we believe can be a
long-term solution where the Palestinian
people really have a chance to live a
better life that's really the best way
to get there there's tons of complicated
factors uh but that's the end state that
the global Community should be looking
to come together and it's very
achievable it's very very very
achievable so there's a as we stand here
today there's a lot of different ways
that this war can evolve if a ground
Invasion
happens uh by Israeli forces of Gaza and
if the number is correct of 100,000
Israeli soldiers do you worry about
various trajectories that can take uh of
the consequences that might have of of
an
unprecedented ground troop attack yeah
so I think as a leader you know you
can't change yesterday but you have the
ability to change tomorrow and that's a
very important uh fundamental I mean
that that's true for all of us not just
leaders but you know we saw with uh with
911 how America was caught off guard uh
by a terrorist attack we acted um you
know somewhat rationally somewhat
emotionally uh which led to a 20-year
war with trillions of dollars lost you
know the I think almost a million lives
lost not just American but all lives and
it was a total tragedy what occurred um
I think right now the Temptation is to
to be strong I think that that's that's
a necessity I do think eliminating risk
is the right objective I think the goal
should be to stay very clear about what
the objective is but also um this attack
was very well planned uh not to walk
into another trap I think you have to be
very smart very cautious I've been happy
to see that what they've been doing uh
in retaliation so far has been uh
somewhat measured and they've taken
their time to try to assess uh what's
achievable again I don't have access to
the intelligence and you know we're
talking at a very early stage uh in this
conflict so a lot could happen even by
the time this is published but um but my
My Hope Is that um they'll just stay
very focused on what the objective is
and try to make sure that they're acting
appropriately in order to do that and I
will say this too that this has been
different than what I've seen in the
past and that the uh the the attacks
were so um heinous and so um so
disgusting ing that I've seen the
International Community rally around
Israel more so than I ever have and I
hope that Israel continues to keep the
moral High ground and continue to
communicate what they're fighting for
why they're fighting um and I do hope
that the international community
supports the objective and they can work
together to achieve
it